vous savez ce qui se passe s'il manque
un joueur à grant holly c'est idiot ne
s'est pas réveillé je peux plus attendre
le match va commencer
vous êtes prêts oui on est prêt mais
quel idiot mamie je peux jouer tu veux
jouer
oui je ne sais pas trop ce qu'elle a dit
à l'entraîneur de green dolly écoutez
moi mon petit fils veut jouer non ils
sont trop grands pour lui qui sait jouer
au foot lui est très bien il était
tellement petit que personne ne croyait
en lui je sais pas il est petit tu as
quel âge presque six ans il court comme
une fusée tu super quoi aucun nom sont
et rapide
je vais te mettre sur l'ale aller en
fils ce maillot et vient jouer à les
bonhommes dépêche toi fils c'est le plus
jeune des messies 6,7 joue comme ses
frères
on a peut-être une chance
timéo montrent leur montre leur allait
il a le ballon
le sla
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment votre petit fils bien
joué au yoyo
[Musique]
il l'a engagé et ça a été du délire avec
il récupérer le ballon
il passait plusieurs joueurs quand ils
étaient à grande eau lit je jouais à
horizonte je suis plus âgé je jouais
dans la catégorie supérieure
il jouait comme un dieu il passait tout
le monde
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez l'amener tous les après midi
à l'entraînement les autres à prendre en
quelque chose quand rodrigo mathias et
tous les grands étaient là bas ils ne
nous laissez pas joué elle est ou non
plus mais les on avait tellement envie
qu'ils le laisser jouer et disait blessé
paléo jouer il est trop petit on risque
de le blesser mais plus tard ils ont
avoué que c'était pour éviter la honte
de se faire dribbler par les eaux
[Musique]